good evening and
welcome I'm Bill CER I am one of the
governors along with John Bloom and John
Lasser of the short films feature
animation branch of the motion picture
Academy and let's all wish a happy 10th
anniversary to the animated feature
Oscar category
I was honored to be in the committee 10
years ago when this was proposed and I
have to tell you getting the academy to
agree to give a new Oscar is like
breaking an eel over your knee it's very
difficult but they did it uh but think
about it you know the animated features
and Snow White no medium in Motion
Pictures has been more popular or more
successful around the world
world I said medium and not genre which
is an important distinction and I think
this category has been a great Testament
in the last 10 years to the versatility
of the animated film to tell stories I
mean think about it we've had the
fanciful who done it mystery of and
comedy and stop motion of Wallace and
grommet the curse of the we rabbit we've
had the compelling drama handdrawn of
prilis we've had the seat gripping
action adventure of stereoscopic 3D with
How to Train Your Dragon and who can
forget how's Moving
Castle or Coraline spiderweb and how
about that stunning jellyfish sequence
in Finding
Nemo and that spectacular lead vocal
performance in
Ratatouille
so so since Shrek won the very first
Oscar in this category 10 years ago
we've had we actually had two of the
nominees go on to also become Best
Picture nominees that's quite an
accomplishment there is a lot to live up
to for just one decade but the
filmmakers tonight and their films have
certainly done it we have again five
films that are great art great
entertainment and great animated
films and tonight they're all winners no
envelopes yes
so to lead us to this historic occasion
we have a talented and hilarious guy
he's an author he's a writer he's a
standup comedian he's an animation
voiceover actor he's now an acclaimed
liveaction actor and he's a multi-grammy
nominee as a matter of fact one of his
albums is called finest hour but maybe
if we give him an unbelievably huge
round of applause he may consider this
his finest Hour ladies and gentlemen
Patton Oswald
thank you Bill oh man oh my God Bill
cyer ladies and gentlemen yes right out
of the American Eagle Outfitter
catalog he going to go chop a cord of
wood maybe skin a moose um that is a
rugged looking dude that is not what you
picture like a guy associated with
movies they you would associate like
more like a guy looks like me just kind
of pasty and sort of sitting in the New
Beverly every night you look like you
were topping trees up in Koz Bay Oregon
and then sure I'll talk about scorsi
what do you
need um Pat and Oswell could not make it
tonight I am Andy Circus thank you so
much for coming out to this I really
don't want to do a long intro I I am a
I'm such an animation nerd I want to
watch these clips I want to talk to
these filmmakers um just this is my in
my opinion as as an animation nerd as a
film buff uh this category this year for
the Oscars I think had the most genuine
surprises it is the most uh diverse
really shows you how um
unlike unlike liveaction film animation
is going through a continuing mutation
and Revolution not just from years ago
but every single year something new and
amazing comes out from from you know big
budget stuff like like Rango like uh
Puss and Boots to to smaller you know
stuff like like a a cat in Paris and uh
and just I mean just every single year
there is something uh new going on in
this category so it it just it I it was
an honor for me to get to post this
evening so we're going to meet all these
filmmakers and we're going to watch some
clips but first Jack and Jill in its
entirety here we go we're are we not no
all right
um uh the first clip we're going to show
oh I uh I got to actually did some
punch-up on
this um but we're not showing the clip
with the fart joke so sorry none of my
work is going to be in this next one uh
this is uh Kung Fu Panda 2 so put your
3D glasses on yes and uh and afterwards
we're going to what what we're going to
do is we'll show you the clip and then
when it's done I will introduce the
director we're going to sit in those
Center chairs and we'll chat and it's
going to be charming and delightful it's
going to be like Mike Douglas in 1973 so
you guys are going to absolutely love it
and then we'll each do a shot and then
we'll do the next uh
clip and when my bottle of talisker is
empty the evening's
over uh so ladies and gentlemen uh this
a clip from The Amazing Kung Fu Panda
what is this place I'm surprised you
remember so little but you were so
little when it
happened perhaps you do
remember now what it's just a stupid
nightmare nightmare or
memory
this was a thriving Village young Shen
was in line to rule Gan City but he
wanted more I foretold that someone
would stand in his way a panda but I
never could have foretold what came
next
get them
all take our son and run away
go
stop
fighting let it
flow
oh
m
a
your story may not have such a happy
beginning but that doesn't make you who
you are it is the rest of your
story who you choose to
be
so who are you panda
I am
Po and I'm going to need a
hat
yeah ladies and Gentlemen please welcome
director Jennifer y
Nelson
hang on they're gonna oh oh they just
turned on test yours see if it works
test test test
nice um I keep thinking people still
have their 3D glasses on but they're
just on the top of people's heads or
there are very tall people out there
with weird neck problems um um so uh I
know this is uh you've probably been
asked this question a million times I
hate to to bother you with it again but
you are the first woman to direct a
major fulllength animated movie by
myself Yeah by yourself
well and uh also I think technically you
directed the highest grossing movie ever
directed by a woman that's really weird
yeah
exactly what um so were you did you
always want to direct animation or what
did you kind of did you kind of fall
backwards into this or like how did you
start what was the I think I what was
your journey Jennifer here Nelson I
tripped and face planted into it really
because um I really didn't plan any of
this I don't plan anything um um but I
really love doing storyboards I'm an
artist I draw right and I've been
drawing my whole life and I've always
had movies running in my head live
action movies strangely enough and the
only way I could figure out how to get
it out of my head into something else
was drawing it and I was doing
storyboards before I realized that there
was something called
storyboards oh really that's you you
just thought you had invented
it and then you read about Spielberg and
go Spielberg you do oh I thought my gosh
you could get paid doing that that's
awesome but I didn't realize that there
were such a thing like that I could use
that for until College because Dave
Lowry who does a lot of steelberg movies
came by to talk at my class in at calate
Long Beach and he showed us his
storyboards and he showed us Willow oh
really and and I was like whoa that's
crazy you draw the movies and they make
the movies after you've drawn them
that's really cool and in a weird way
doing storyboards totally prepped you
for directing because you have to choose
in storyboards the right have you ever
when you were doing this did you ever
storyboard stuff and and let's say you
map out six of the frames or scenes then
go oh no that's not like and then
totally scrap it because you realize
there's a better way to approach it
absolutely because storyboard is the
cheapest time to be doing that yeah ex
you shouldn't be doing that on the set
when you're like we we'll do eight
different setups to day and see what
happens when I'm doing my own sequences
cuz I like to draw my story boards
myself sometimes I have an amazing
storyboard crew oh really but I also
like to draw some myself I hoard some
for myself yeah yeah I got to um but
what I tend to do when I'm doing my own
sequences is I have to pace around and
get it done in my head first MH and that
may take a whole day and then I'll start
to draw and when I draw it I'm not
thinking at that point I just
print were there were there ever though
times that you would let's say you
storyboard something out and then you
direct it and do cuz I I know I know a
little bit about when they go back and
redo sequences and stuff like that there
was there a sequence where you were so
sure oh this is the way to do it and
when you saw it in motion you're like oh
no that's wrong I've got to redo that or
did you ever get that far into it all
the time because you you deal with a lot
of different input from a lot of very
very smart and talented people who give
ideas
and you may have it's a very
collaborative medium every single
Department it goes into someone add
something it's like stone soup right
yeah and then all of a sudden you've got
amazing soup yeah that you just uh I was
just going to boil water with the stone
in it but if we're going to add carrots
I'm not going to say no I mean please um
did you uh uh how do I okay so when you
were um you suddenly you're doing a
sequel to
Kung Fu pan Which is this amazingly
successful film and and and that I
remember I forgot in the sequence you
also kind of did 2D a total nod to
Miyazaki then you're doing Shaw Brothers
Kung Fu action like you you could not
have been giving yourself more and more
obstacles and challenges to do on did
you do that on purpose I mean I mean
that's like a that that's almost like an
announcement it's almost like the way
like a a great like hip-hop artist
announces how awesome they are by by
crushing in every style they can on
their first album so this is like this
is like your Notorious BIG ready to die
like oh yeah I'm going to do the whole
spectrum of everything did you have that
in mind how are you like a gangster
rapper um not very much well I I guess
you said you have a storyboard crew I
mean you guys I have a storyboard crew
at my head you guys you guys go over to
Pixar and throw down maybe uh do a
little driveby with the blue pencils or
something like
I do not fight well I think I'd break my
hands on piece of paper and those hands
are precious those are story boarding
instruments head I head of stories
actually here here Phil Craven and uh
he's over there somewhere oh Fair nice
and also Ramon zebach a production
designer but those are the people I work
with they're amazingly talented people
and something like those 2D sequences
you should see just the art that came
out of it we just took that art and
moved it and that's the thing that was
just so wonderful about doing those 2D
sequences we don't have to interpret at
all from the concept painting that's the
concept painting moving you got to make
but you've got to make the painting move
and make the movement kind of live up to
the painting so in a way it is
challenging or at least maybe it could
be intimidating it could be but we're
all such fans of it it's such a nice
time to be able to show 2D animation 3D
animation 3D stereo and there's and all
of it used to tell a story in that
sequence for instance the stereo was
used to follow the mother in depth as
she kind of disappears off into the snow
in depth so between the 3D and the 2D
between the water drop and the mom is
exactly the same spatial place we're
using 3D to tell the story emotionally
and so that that's like was fun and also
show like incredible violence of like
wrecking a village and stuff yeah I make
it pretty well it's you make violence
very gorgeous it is interesting to see
how so many liveaction movies this year
are going back and using the techniques
that animators have known about for
decades now especially if you watch like
Hugo and see how they they they learned
very wisely use 3D more for depth rather
than stuff zipping in your face right to
add and you see a lot of that in the in
the um fight sequences this film it's
used as a as a real legitimate tool and
it's not a gimmick you can use it to
reinforce emotion you can use it to
reinforce action or just just reinforce
just how it feels to be a
space wow okay the one last question I'm
sure that a lot of animators get this
now but since watching this movie you
made an amaz I mean Beyond it being a
gorgeous animated film and and a
wonderful characters you made a kickass
Kung Fu film you made a great action
film on top of everything else and you
clearly I mean she did this is she made
a great kung fu movie and you clearly
know how to zip bodies around in space
for Maximum Impact any plans to ever do
live action especially action like you
clearly know what the hell you're doing
I mean that would be my dream come true
actually some there to make a really
kickass cyborg movie oh really oh yeah
because you got to have cyborg cuz that
you still have to have licens to kind of
lose gravity and you know kick through
walls oh yeah yeah exactly I mean look
Streep and Gary man are brilliant they
can only do so much you have to justify
why they're flying through the air
there's a reason why Jean clavon dos in
this movie as a cameo cuz I grew up
watching his cyborg movie I was like
that is so cool I love how we're at the
Academy and and people are going to be
invoking scorsi and Wells you're like
vanam buddy cyborg that is the basis of
all Cinema as far as I'm concerned man
you can burn everything that came before
vanam cyberg there's no point there's no
point start from cyborg build from
there Jennifer it was awesome talking to
you thank you so much we're going to see
you again at the end we're going to come
back and then you guys get to ask them
questions probably far better than me so
thank you so
much one more for Jennifer come on yeah
awesome okay we're going to show another
uh sequence from a 3D uh film this is uh
Puss and Boots uh which I also did punch
up on my big note at a panda who does
Kung Fu they did not get it they were
not happy um Chris Miller uh who
directed this uh he had a family
commitment he loves animation he does
not like people who enjoy animation so
he says he's very sorry he couldn't be
here um he does apparently he does not
like people enjoying his work it's weird
he's a weird guy um so uh put your uh
glasses back on here comes puss and
boots thank
you
those magic beings were my score you
just caus me a chance at getting the
golden eggs M amigo put up your
Turks
very well if it is to be a dance fight
then I will Tuesday night dance fight
you to the
death
how dare you do the little box on
me and
so
can you feel
me
a
fear me if you
dare
you hit me in the head with a guitar you
you're a woman
oh wow
I'm
mature
wow I I forgot about that little cat
going that was awesome um well now uh
you can take your uh 3D glasses off for
the rest of the evening uh we're going
to wait don't go like oh man now we just
got to watch 2D come
on my Lord people um see this is how
cool again the animation category is
those were two yes those were two very
big budget 3D uh bodies flying through
the air Defying Gravity awesome fun
movies now we get to Chico and Rita uh
yeah
which that is
how amazing and diverse this category is
big budget films get nominated in this
category smaller personal Innovative in
in my opinion riskier movies uh get
nominated there was a really interesting
review by Roger Ebert about this movie
today on his website you should go read
where he's basically uh saying that the
story and characterizations are so good
that and yet it doesn't really take
place in a Fantastical Animated Universe
but you don't mind that it's animated
the the the art and the kind of toned
down feeling of it actually brings you
into the world better than if it were
live action which I think is such a
testament to this art form and uh we're
going to watch a clip and then we're
going to talk to the two directors and I
just want to say their names because
it's so fun saying their names listen to
these names ready Fernando
truba and Javier
mariscal oh those names I want to fight
a duel all right um ladies and gentlemen
here uh is a clip from CH
read
that
was hit that one out
of cool man get back in New
York you really nailed that man good job
you nailed
that
[__] uh can ED is too
hey [__] you
bastard
[__] I
got do
not watch out
get
fore
speeech
spe
BL
oh gorgeous that was gorgeous ladies and
gentlemen Fernando chuba and Javier
marisco oh yeah right right there grab a
mic now uh Fernando uh you are uh pretty
well known for uh an Oscar speech that
you gave uh back in 1993 when you said
uh I feel like I want to thank God but
instead I'll just thank Billy
Wilder yeah yeah that was you now I I
heard that the next day I was younger oh
you were a little
younger um did didn't Billy Wilder call
you you the next day yeah yeah they they
he told me Fernando why you say that now
people that see me on the street they
they do the sign of the
cross wow so you kind of uh made things
a little rough form or maybe a little
easier who knows do you have tape across
your
stomach sorry oh I was like I don't know
what was going on there for a
second if you had like a medical
condition that I didn't know about or I
was like don't mention the tape across
the stomach Paton was was on on the
chair oh okay do you think that we have
to tape ourselves into the chairs for
the 3D or something or oh for the love
of God oh
boy you laugh now but he'll be selling
it on eBay to some animation nerd no I'm
good I'm quite
good so tell the um yeah exactly it'll
be there when you need it
later I read the story of how you guys
got together on this to do the uh movie
so why don't you tell the story of how
you two met
to actually decide to do
animation and actually make it a
movie
uh uh okay you know I learn English with
the beetles in the beachs mhm so I don't
understand
you you learned English with the Beatles
and and like the beatnicks and stuff
like that why in the Beats okay well
walking around look Daddy O why don't
you lay down the J as to how you guys
you know kind of got
copasetic and uh sort of you know filled
the sprockets with all them little
cartoony uni
unies I'm sorry I'm sorry no it's
okay uh I was the beginning of this
movie it was our friendship we wanted to
work together so he's a painter designer
illustrator I'm a filmmaker so what we
can do together an animation movie so it
was an old dream of him to to make a
feature movie he he had work uh shorter
things for TV and and that in animation
and uh for me it was really my first
experience in in that field and uh and I
so it was born of our friendship or
desire of working together and then we
we thought what what things uh we share
we share the love for Cuba and it's uh
it's culture it's music jazz New York
Avana all this so we we did a movie
where we put a lot of the things that we
really love so and uh it's a it's a
friendship work this yeah we we love
this music we love laana we love New
York we love also Las Vegas and La yeah
yeah it's my prefer City man
yeah it's the only place I understand
English in
California many times I fly to London
you know what I mean yeah it's
impossible to understand these people
you know so maybe you should learn
English from guy Richie films that would
definitely help yeah watch a few of
those so we we we want to say this
compar share No to share these wonderful
things with many many many millions of
people but now we we only share with 500
people okay yeah you know very good
reviews but uh there are no a
book in the marketing you know people
say are you crazy they are not a books
for animated adults say but it's not
AIS adults you know what I mean no yeah
I I know what you're
yeah Hey I'm
hipcat um did you ever hipat did you
what mean hipat uh hipcat please you
know you speak you are a minority uh-huh
yeah I know speak English a minority
most millions of people in China in
Japan in
Filipinas in India yeah in France in
German they speak like
me
so we are
majority take it easy
please you can make fantastic jokes but
thinking in people speak only Italian
like me okay are you Roberto bonini in
Disguise is my brother wow you know the
the style of of of Art and animation in
this did you ever start off like or have
ever done like comic books or graphic
novels it has a really like you know ink
and Pen sort of feel to it that I I mean
have you ever done sequential art stuff
like that like in in book form or has it
always been like designing and stuff for
film yeah yes it
is no he's done a lot of of of work on
comic books and design and illustration
and comics and everything mhm his lamps
from oh some lamps red carpets uhhuh
yeah it's true I make a lot of rocks and
textile for for fashion and
for interior design
hotels even I can design something for
you a new
shoes I wish I had 8 hours with you I
really do oh my goodness um I I've been
with him seven years in I'm
sorry imagine that I know it's it's aged
you visibly I still love him I'm so
sorry couldn't
resist it's good it's good the tape's
still back there it's good it's very
good oh it's very good yes yeah okay we
are we are going to we're going to you
you're going to come come back later and
take questions from the audience so
thank you guys so much for coming here
and letting us do this awesome to talk
to you thank you leave your mic yes
there you
go feel like I've caused an
international incident somehow oh
no um
oh these next guys are French here we
go oh
boy I'll just stick to talking about
Jerry Lewis I
guess next film that we're going to show
is a cat in Paris and yeah
um hey guys made this is their first
feature film this is their first feature
film boom right out of the gate
nomination
pow yeah so they'll probably never be
heard from again if uh if the Oscar
curse stays fo so
um uh let's uh well I mean I'll talk to
them after this but uh I oh their name's
really cool to say too and they wrote it
out phonetically because I want to make
sure to say it right but they really
sound awesome ready here we go elain
gool is that right oh cool and Jean Lou
phel Fel
Olo oh no no felicioli
Jean Lou felicioli oh that worked better
ladies and gentlemen we're going to talk
to them in just a second but for now a
cat in
Paris
foree
foreign
fore
Oh's see
come
for any Moe
spee
foreign
say don't
Mane
I
wish something
knew
I on April
day that would not Dan
s
i
star to me a be
more wish
star and ask for
dream I look for every liness
it all came
true I was St the
Moon
for
forign
spee
fore
fore foreign
speech
oh that was
gorgeous I haven't seen that movie yet I
I have to go see that I'm going to be
honest I have not seen that movie that
was awesome ladies and Gentlemen please
welcome Elaine gagol
and John Lou felicioli
translator thank God okay
um we we are French so we can speak
English oh okay don't let's not please
why are
let's not start a a weird war here okay
oh and then World War III started with
animators it always was was always going
to start that way
um this uh and everything I say Ad he
said sexily at the end of it just add
that
um the
uh no
no really damn oh okay
um this this movie it from what what I
just saw it feels like it has the has
the the logic and the feel of like a
classic children's book
almost
yes were do and and were you going for
that look with the the colors almost
look like they're um drawn in with like
colored pencils it has that rich feel to
it was that also a thing that you were
going for
or
yes
I hate my job as a translator this isn't
Patton speaking now it's actually me
let's get away from these horrible nerds
please take me away to Paris I can't
stand my life here in Los Angeles it is
a Cess pool of shallowness this is me
speaking to you I have fallen madly in
love with you during this tour get me
the hell out of this
city
damn
it
um uh what well I mean what what made
what Drew you to this project what made
you want I mean this is your first film
this is so unique what what Drew you to
it
ah so uh we we worked on on a lot of
shorts together and I'm also the author
of um um uh gangster
novels
what what gangster novels have you
written oh you don't know them oh they'
they've never been translated into a no
no so you kind of combined it's CU it's
very film Noir it looks film Noir but
then there's like Kitty stuff in it too
little kid stuff not like cat
stuff
the night of the
hunter I heard night of the hunter go
ahead so yes we're very big fans of nor
American movies and obviously we all R
Walsh night of the
hunter have you ever been to the I've
always wanted to go to I I I was in
Paris for 24 hours I didn't have a
chance to go to the cinematech France
have you ever been there to see movies
no because we are not a Parisian we live
in the the south of France very little
town Kelo
P
um um I can say yes if you want okay
good yeah be good just I would keep it
to yeses
um uh God I uh
so
um what was this how much of this was
done on Compu this this feels so
handdrawn how much was done on computers
how much was just totally
handrawn the animation is and drawn but
the the colors are made by computer
really yeah except the sorry
Von I got the one word I
remember Yes except the the lights on
the characters they are drawn by
a sorry I'm I'm going to speak your
French sorry I must look at you that's
okay that's okay yes the the actual
lighting the lights on the characters
are actually you know uh drawn with
pencil and actually the decor is is uh
is drawn with chalk wow so did but did
you have to for the colors on the
computer did you cuz I remember when I
was at at Pixar they had to teach the
computer to make things sort of sloppier
to make it real did you have to teach
the computer to keep the the chalk
texture for the color keep the pencil
texture or something like that is that a
good
question
yes so
well yes yes oh God James lipt in is
spinning in his grave right now
um uh one last one last
question I could I could I have never
felt more American in my life I've never
felt more American this is so
embarrassing um who are your who are
your favorite animators either American
or worldwide who influence you animation
wise don't say
yes
F oh okay mag
uhuh what is your favorite 7s Prague
rock band whose lead singer was named
John Anderson
I don't
know the answer is
yes damn it all right um thank guys
thank you so much thank wow I'm ni that
was gorgeous beautiful beautiful thank
you beautiful
wow
bravo bravo another round of applause
those
oh that is that that's the price you pay
for G being nominated to deal with an
idiot like me sorry that's that's the
universe balancing itself out um our
last clip uh is from Rango and
unfortunately gor verbinski could not be
here but he has sent he has sent a
message and before we show this message
I would like to make make a confession
um I also uh punched up Rango I punch up
everything and um I was uh Gore and I
argued tooth and nail over Rango I said
knowing everything that I thought I knew
about animation and how it works and how
kids respond to things that uh oh this
the lizard's too creepy looking he
doesn't have any eyes there's nothing
expressive there he's coldblooded kids
don't like that kids don't care about
Chinatown audiences don't care I swear
to God I was saying all these things
like literally speaking from on
highlight let me tell you a little
something about movies and so it just
goes to show you that this category this
art form can constantly constantly take
risks and throw out even the rules not
just the rules of film making the rules
of gravity um and literally the rules of
physics they can throw out its own
established rules that is what a vital
and and continually growing
um art form this is even Beyond film so
I was I've never been more glad to have
been proven wrong and and to be reminded
that you still have so much to learn in
your life and uh and and and someone is
going to roll the dice with movies like
this so I I thank him I thank him her
for handing me my ass I I absolutely do
so uh ladies and gentlemen uh gor rinsky
um are we showing the clip first and
then
Gore okay um was that the French guy
say
um Sean
Lou
um we're going to show the clip first
and then a message from
cor
Rango
listen close Heap that fraud this is my
town now if I ever see you again I will
take your soul straight down to
Hell
Who Who Are
You
for
who am
I I'm
nobody
oh
with you this evening to celebrate all
the achievements this year in animation
to me among these nominees is an honor I
can't begin to describe uh we had the
best time making Rango and I'm humbled
by its recognition thank you for
welcoming me in the neurotic lizard into
your world it is a world I can't wait to
return to and um I hope you guys have a
fantastic evening cheers thank
you wow that was so sweet um okay well
let's bring our five
uh filmmakers back up to the stage uh to
take your questions so uh ladies and
gentlemen uh please uh let's bring up uh
each one in turn of course uh sorry uh
Jennifer y Nelson ladies and
gentlemen here she
comes do some like forward cartwheels I
good yeah uh Fernando truba and Javier
mariscal
and of course elain gagol and jeanl
felicioli
I'm gonna hover around behind you and
take uh questions from the audience oh
can I sit down there is
there no no you guys sit there you guys
sit there I'm going to I'm going to
wander around
um oh look at that oh I love that it's
like it's like You guys' album cover
it's cute yes yeah oh yeah all right
stole your thing and um oh that's very
nice what do you want to sit down there
no you want to sit oh
this sorry I'm I'll be hosting the
awkward Awards tomorrow night
um okay uh so I guess are we opening
this up for uh questions from the
audience if you have any is there a mic
floating around or how are we going to
do this two of them two of them are
floating around um if you want to put
the house sits up a little bit on the
audience we can see who has a question
um the first hand that goes up is the
hardest hand and then everyone else wow
boom right there oh that's the first one
I saw I'm sorry maybe you were first
but here we go evening
whoa with uh Kung Fu Panda where we saw
the uh handdrawn animation do you think
it's coming back in American Cinema uh
as featurelength films or is it being
more integrated
within computer animated films is
another form um I actually think that
it's totally viable to make it into a
featurelength film I think that it's
more possible now than it was maybe five
years ago where everyone was going CG's
it and that's that's everything else is
done but there are so many good things
coming out in 2D and frankly there are
some shockingly amazing talented artists
that do it and love to do it and I had
to like you know have almost a lottery
for the people to actually animate the
2D shop in the movie likely the two
people that did it rodolph and Pierre
are just insanely good but there are so
many people who can do it and I think
that it's being seen as a possibility
now as opposed to a little while before
it wasn't hopefully there'll be
more
okay um sit here I could I I can see
better if you're sitting here I'll be
down there you can take your notes with
you that's cool thanks oh yes yes yes
all right um our next question
is oh there's one over there weighing
it's yes there he
goes um I have a question for a cat in
Paris how long did it take to shoot the
film oh
sorry uh
puzzle it took three years to
make is it like hard to do
it was really really hard to do
yes oh okay wow that was question over
here oh over
there Hi um my name is Jose I'm actually
a film student right now at the Los
Angeles Film school and I just wanted to
congratulate all of the filmmakers here
it's really an honor to be
here
um my question is uh what is one of the
main lessons that you learned uh in the
film making process for each of your
films in uh I answered just by myself
I'm a uh it's my first animation movie
I've done live action movies before and
I learn a lot uh May in ch and Rita but
I still consider myself completely
ignorant in animation and uh but I I
learn a lot and it open for me like a
window in my head and I discovered that
uh there there's there are some stories
that uh can uh told uh can better be
told in animation than in uh in live
action or in documentary I think I think
I discovered that animation is a very
specific way not just for for a movie
for children but for certain kind of
stories so I I want to keep on working
uh on on animation after this experience
and I I'm also making live action movies
obviously as
always yeah well he's telling me that I
I I've been working for several years in
a documentary project uh I I have like
one50 or 60 hours of of for this
documentary and uh in the making of
during the making of CH and Rita I decid
to uh make that movie into a an
animation movie so it's it's one project
that we are thinking to do uh as soon as
we can you're doing an animated
documentary
uh no no I discover that uh it's going
to be a mix of uh documentary and and uh
fiction because it's it's it's an
investigation it's the story of a uh
Brazilian pianist jazz pianist who was
kidnapped and killed and his body
disappeared in Argentina in the
70s so uh
after months of thinking about it I I
really uh discovered that I should do
that in animation that I can do some
things that never in a documentary or in
a live action movie I could be uh I I I
could do so that's why I decide to make
it into an animation because it I found
it was the best way to tell that
specific
story you want to answer um
learning process uh there's so much
stuff that I had to learn every single
day because I hadn't directed before I
mean being ahead of story you're
involved in the storytelling a lot
you're you're seeing a lot of the film
but being a director you walk into a
room and people just look right at you
and you better have an
answer and and that was really scary but
at the same time one thing that I really
learned was why anyone would want to
make an animated film in that you work
with some amazing people and everybody
in the room are sitting there and
they're all artists they all either draw
on the computer or Draw in person and on
hand or whatever but everyone one of
them is an artist everyone just wants to
do an amazing thing and so that amount
of support was just really wonderful I'm
I was scared to death the whole time but
it was really nice to have a crew that
supported me to that
degree
we have made um 14 short movies before
before the the fature film and the big
difference is uh that with the feature
film we can meet the the audience short
movies are it's very difficult to to see
them and I think it I I have learned a
lot with the meeting with the the
audience you it's a way to to learn is
his job how to make movie you can see
the reaction and it was very very
interesting I'm not sure I learned
anything let's not ask ask ourselves a
question um should we well I I learned
something fantastic is is working in a
big big team and
and and I I I don't know how you say
when somebody have only one one arm you
know
so I I I always feel like that you
know and other people was the other hand
and the other and that's is fantastic
because you you you see how limited you
are and the others together you know
it's like hand CET people working
together and he very very good they I
love animation
people they are all around the world and
is very very nice people very very
good oh
yeah oh
yeah uh there's a hand up right there um
what was the hardest part about making
these
projects that was Ralph machio by the
way that's so odd that he's here so
weird guy does not
age
um the hardest part for me was um I'm
kind of very
introverted
so actually having to to make 350 people
all sort of
um uh make one project with me when I
don't talk very
much it was very difficult and um I'm
glad that it worked worked
out for me the the hardest thing was to
wait all time waiting waiting for
finding the money waiting and and once
the the production the animation started
waiting for every single shot to be made
it was now after all the the
work with the story boarding and doing
the music and the voices and the whole
all these things then one day the first
shot arrived and it was like 5 seconds
and I was so happy and I say when are we
going to have another
one and they told me two
months my God so I I spent two months
watching this 5 Seconds all the
time
well for me the more difficult ones in
the beginning
beginning
um you know I I'm an illustrator too and
but I am designer
so
I I try to understand what kind of story
we want to tell and so quickly I I see
my illustration there are too much
caricature or too much uh uh far away or
far out
or keep keep keep on
Crossing well so I I working a lot to
find a a industrial system industrial
new style and thanks I have very good
animators in my Studio very very close
to me like uh 15 years working together
so so quick no not so
quickly after one year we Define the
style and the style wise after read all
the time the the script so all all the
time my work was try to define something
good for for tell this
story and find the colors of labana and
find the colors of New York
and and I don't know try if if I I do
myself only with three or four people
was more more free more maybe
interesting but uh was impossible so we
Define something
more uh Industrial in and we we I I was
very very happy to see how people from
Philippines or for Hungary or for France
or for Madrid or from Barcelona or from
Brazil Brazil Rio Hano or even from
England they working together and thanks
to my brother tono he's the also the
another
director he he make a a very complex
system by internet you know I very old
so I remember all my life was no
internet you
know and that helps a lot and and I
remember when I was 21 years old in the
71 I started alone myself and make after
3 weeks I make 20 second of a very
simple animation I say w I must
waiting so this was but in in the same
time we laughing a lot a lot a lot and
it's wonderful make animation because
you can smoke good marijuana and and and
laughing and everything is mov man is
good it's
good
oh did you um one we have a question oh
okay sorry the mic
is thank you all for coming um just a
quick question now I know that like
Jennifer for example your movie is a
fantasy picture and it's also an action
movie so now when you're making two
genres into one so fluidly how do you
know that the characters in the universe
you create are working is it at the
script stage is it at the storyboard
stage is at the production design stage
where you're saying the fantasy elements
are just fantastic enough for people to
believe it but then the action elements
are just are just shot well enough and
boarded well enough for it to be that
believable as well well we don't tend to
think about whether it's fantasy or the
the genre we mainly think about story we
start with story we start with
characters what the characters want what
the characters need and that's something
that happens in a science fiction
picture a picture in some fantasy
environment or you know on a cafe down
the street it's a liveaction thing it's
an animated thing it's really based on
character and what the characters are
are needing and doing over the course of
the movie so we do that first and we
will figure out what we're trying to say
with the movie first with three or four
people in a room with a whiteboard and a
lot of chocolate and we sit there and
think really hard for a very long time
trying to make sure that we get the
point of the movie across and that's
when we start thinking about how are we
going to show it how are we going to
present it but that is execution it's
not a part of what is the spine of the
movie and that is very very early that's
before the script and that's when we're
just working it out on posted cards on
the
wall chocolate is DreamWork slang for
marijuana
um is
there I think we only have time for
there's like one more question Sor right
right in the middle we'll go to the
middle this is for the cat and Paris
filmmakers your film has a lot of action
sequences in it and the Big Challenge
both with live action and animation with
action sequences are keeping them
character driven and story oriented and
you guys did a remarkable job of that
and I was hoping you could talk about
the challenge of keeping that in your
action sequences of an animated
film touche
translator
for
it's not an easy question do you want to
try to uh simplify it just a
tad make it a yes or no
question
St
so um we we spend a lot of time actually
uh conceiving uh at the stage of
storyboard um when we work on
storyboards uh we make sure that um we
um frame the image um really clearly and
properly so that we give them enough
space within the frame to move and
evolve but um but but the overall image
remains pretty clear and
simple the overall image remains clear
and simple what a perfect way to end
this evening that's a great wow thank
you um another round of applause for all
of our amazing filmmakers this evening
oh Alain
gagol Jean Lou um
foli Jennifer you
Nelson um friend hang on I damn it I'm
blanking yes and and uh uh jaier marier
marisal yes ladies and gentlemen
oh thank you guys so
much